how long should a host set be how many
minutes should a host speak in between
comics
when should a host pull a comic off the
stage when should a host
tossed an unruly audience member whoo
a lot of great questions that we will
definitely dive head first into
on that on the workshop for sure robin
but even just glancing a host a good
opening set
five to ten minutes a good hosting set
at a comedy club they're going to expect
you to typically
do 10 minutes a 10 minute set
um how much should a host speak in
between comics how many minutes
i would say a minute just keep the show
moving keep the show rolling
uh when should a host pull a comic off
the stage
if they're bombing or if they're running
the light if they're ignoring the light
and just continuing to go
um if they're bombing you can eventually
just
go up there and start applauding
if they're if they're bombing and you're
giving them the light or
they're being disrespectful and they're
giving the light and they're not getting
off
you can go up there and make it a fun
thing the whole audience knows they're
bombing
by the way the whole audience knows
they're bombing so
you can make it a fun thing where we're
all in this together and we're slow
clapping the comic off the stage
um hopefully you don't have to do that
much
and what should i when should i host
toss an unruly audience member
yeah it's tough to toss an audience
member as a host unless you like own the
venue
what you can do is speak to the manager
speak to management of the venue and be
like hey this
audience members being very unruly and
disrespectful and they're saying some
very vulgar things
could you help take care of that type
deal you don't put it all on yourself
thanks for watching this clip if you
found these tips helpful and you want to
get involved in our hosting workshop
go into the show description and request
to join our hot breath
pro facebook group if you're looking to
level up your comedy
that is the group for high you